hey guys this is Pete peppers and this
is a candy crush soda saga level 505
walkthrough with some commentary this
was the whole last episode was pretty
hard overall I think but this was one of
the levels that had me stuck the longest
and it really kind of drove me nuts
reminded me a lot of what like set level
75 was when the game first came out but
anyways this is a two color chocolate
level the licorice links really aren't
all that important the shape of the
board is the real problem the the two
bottom squares on on either side are
nearly impossible to get to with matches
so we you know we can tell right away we
need to make some big combos to get
through this but at the same time
there's not a lot of space up at the top
and we you know there's a lot of
different colors so it's hard to make
specials and it's even harder to make
combos so I'm gonna go ahead and play
through and talk about some of the
different decisions I had to make
obviously make any color bomb in the
first move is standard although at this
point it's not really that effective if
you can't make a combo out of it because
there's no candy next to the chocolate
anywhere so you know it's cool to make
it but you know in my experience of
playing it
I didn't whenever I had a big bomb match
in the beginning I didn't really ever
get to do much with it and that was the
case with this one too I just want to
head and you know pick the the light
blue because that would give me a
striped candy going down so what I'm
doing here is I'm I'm not necessarily
trying to bust through the link so
instead what I'm trying to do is set up
you know like a wrapped I got a wrapped
in the middle so I'd like to set up a
striped with that if I could so you can
see some of the matches that I'm picking
or off to the side and you might you
know wonder why it's I'm just trying to
set up anything I can at least right now
there's nowhere for the the chocolate to
spread so you know if you can get a
early its gonna do a lot of damage so
you know that's basically the idea you
want to go with so I'm gonna pause for a
second here so you look over the board
and you see where the problem is I mean
we got purple and green those are all
far away from each other they don't they
don't there's no matches we can make
with those colors we have a rap candy
that we could blow up but it's not going
to do much of anything and you know we
really really don't there's really not
much to see here at the time so you know
when you get into playing this level you
really want to take your time and you
want to try to think one move ahead if
you can so let's see what we do here
yeah you're gonna have to do drop this
down now
now the wrapped a little bit better
because we can make a fish with it too
well we're gonna still try to move
things around clearing the links will
give you a little bit more room and that
did actually make the that it actually
work out one other thing here is like
you could see when you fire striped in
that row it doesn't even hit the white
chocolate at the bottom so that makes it
even tougher so now you know I'm gonna
try to get some some cascade and some
more specials and the cascade is
basically you know you know you're in
trouble when you have to rely on the
cascade but this is one of those boards
where you do so you're gonna want to try
to you know hit your chocolate just like
any other one and here here I got the
the color bomb and then I get the fish
set up right after it so this is gonna
pretty much take out the whole thing but
what I was gonna say is is you know
whenever you have when you're kind of
stuck you're gonna want to get the
pieces to drop down right and then the
other thing is is you're going to want
to you're going to want to be able to
like when they're dropping your
want to hit the chocolate like every so
often you know I mean like every other
time or so because the white chocolate
spread so fast as we all know you know
if you let it get out of control you're
never gonna get it back under control
and I mean you know you're probably
struggling with this and you happen
because I know I was like I had times
when I had it all the way down to two
pieces of chocolate just to white
everything else gone with several moves
to go and then I just couldn't get after
it and it spread so fast that the
board's covered before you know it so
trying to do that you know try to try to
hit the chocolate every other time or
every time if you could but at the same
time always get the candies to drop and
always look up a top of the board for
opportunities to set up specials make
specials and set up combos and make the
combos and if you hang in there and take
your time you know you all eventually
get the set up to where you can take
them all out
so I hope this helps if nothing else
it'll give you the feeling that you know
you will eventually get it to work out I
mean like I said I was really frustrated
with this one so I'm sure you probably
are too if you're watching the video but
hang in there it's possible I hope you
like it please like the video subscribe
to my channel let me know if you need
help leave a comment or whatever and I
will be making new videos soon thanks
you